hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mal
wanne und heute gibt es ein ganz
spezielles video und zwar ein mug bang
video
wenn ihr nicht wisst was es ist trigger
warnung ich werde heute essen live vor
der kamera
ich werde auch nicht so großartig
schneiden sondern einfach durchlaufen
lassen und ich habe euch bei twitter ein
paar fragen gestellt die werde ich dann
dazu beantworten
ganz kurz zu erklärung matt bang videos
sind videos in denen die leute essen und
es gibt ganz unterschiedliche videos
also wohl nur gegessen wird und nicht
gesprochen wird
aber viele machen dann auch videos in
dem sie dann essen und dabei halt
quatschen ja es ist sehr komisch ich
weiß aber irgendwie schaue ich mir immer
öfter mal so ein video an und finde es
eigentlich ganz cool weil die halt so
viel erzählen und man irgendwie dabei
abschalten kann und wenn ihr mit mir
essen wollte ich was zu essen und wir
können ganz entspannt zusammen essen
also wäre es absolut nicht mag jemanden
beim essen zuzugucken der kann jetzt
gerne wegschalten ich bin euch nicht
böse
für alle anderen viel spaß und ich hab
sogar ein passendes die stadt dafür
angezogen also wenn ich nicht
vorbereitet finden dann ja dann weiß ich
auch nicht
zuallererst brauchen was zu trinken denn
das ist standard in soma bay video erst
mal schön was für tolle geräusche eva
gut manchmal habe ich beim ersten
eigenes nur schon der erste eindruck
ich habe heute schon ein video gedreht
und das jetzt das zweite und jetzt hab
ich echt hunger bekommen seit ich weiß
dass moderne auch zu uns liefert bin ich
auf ein sehr glücklicher mensch und es
gibt natürlich sushi
ich bin zwar so schön wenn sie zwei
stäbchen mit liefern als ob man noch ein
dabei hätte und nicht alleine vor einer
kamera essen würde oder also so ist das
ja nicht okay erst mal irgendwo mögt ihr
den ingwer ich liebe ihn ja ne super
lecker irgendwie ja ich hab ich bei
twitter fragen gestellt und würde die
jetzt beantworten denn es nicht so viele
werden oh mein gott wo finde ich die
denn dort ok erste frage warum ist die
farbe grün und nehme also die erste
frage von vanessa vanilleeis hallo
vanilleeis
warum ist die farbe grün nicht blau also
es gibt eine oder was ich über farben
weiß ist dass wir auch unterschiedliche
farben sehen könnten
es wäre möglich dass zum beispiel was
ich klett denke was blau ist ist
eigentlich grün aber ich habe einen
fehler und ich habe verschiedene was es
schwer zu erklären
ich brauche erstmal was im magen ach so
ist es vegetarisch weil kein
schweinefleisch für mich vegetarier ab
und zu ab und zu er sich tatsächlich
fleisch
okay das ist so lecker zurück zu den
farben also farben farben farben farben
also wenn ich denke dass etwas grün ist
kann zum beispiel auch blau sein
aber weil von anfang an mir gesagt wurde
dass diese farbe grün ist habe ich sie
jetzt grün bezeichnet
in der realen also es könnte auch jemand
anderes blau sein bestätigtes ich hoffe
schon
ich glaube ja ihr seid doch schlauer ihr
seid schlaf schön chris christie
christian i das ist so lecker ja ich hab
irgendwie von derzeit wegen irgendwas
ich hab's ich wollte gucken was ist so
viele japanische sushi gibt und bin dann
auch so einen auf so ein video gestoßen
wo jemand sushi gegessen hat ich zeige
euch den kanal hier einmal die macht das
irgendwie so sympathisch dass es hat
überhaupt nicht komisch war die hat er
zeit gegessen und so über ihr leben
erzählt ja und da habe ich mir noch mehr
videos von ihr angeguckt und sie ist
halt immer so dabei und redet und das
finde ich halt irgendwie voll cool
keine ahnung
auch glaube ich shane dawson hat das
auch schon gemacht vor der kamera
gegessen
vielleicht ist das der neue trend vor
der kamera essen und die videos nicht
schneiden
super
zum allerersten mal da bestellt und es
ist super super ist das so nächste frage
man bei diesen fingerabdruck erkennt er
manchmal meinen daumen und manchmal
nicht mit technik warum bist du so cool
ja keine ahnung wie lange kenne ich
kenne schon von erdöl 64 carlo er
schlüpfen
kelly kenne ich jetzt seit ich habe vor
zwei jahren
ich glaube drei mal so lange wie ich in
berlin wohne und dann zweieinhalb jahre
lang gewohnt ich denn jetzt in berlin
drei dieses jahr
drei jahre also kenne ich sie
zweieinhalb wir haben uns auf keine kurz
erzählen wir uns kennengelernt haben wir
haben uns auf einen klassischen event
kennen gelernt und zwar hat mich max
damals mitgenommen also der froh und
kenny habe ich dann da getroffen und ich
hab selber natürlich videos geschaut so
ja und und wollte immer schon selber
welche machen und kelly kannte ich auch
schon durch videos und dann habe ich auf
diesen passion play station event
angesprochen und habe gefragt sondern
wie macht man das so und wie ist das so
und sehr einfach gesagt wir machen heute
weiß dass katys grundeinstellung für
alles im leben ist macht einfach
damals dachte ich boah als die cool und
lässig kelly main-tauber-kreis caddies
so cool
ja und dann haben wir uns über die
wochen oder monate immer mal wieder
gesehen und irgendwann war mir plötzlich
freunde
ich weiß gar nicht wann das passiert ist
weil hänni und ich sind gar nicht so
diese zu anhänglich dass wir immer
sogleich zu leuten gehen ich liebe dich
bist du tot
das hat ja das glaube deshalb hat es ein
bisschen länger gedauert
freunde zu werden bei uns beiden aber
ich glaube jetzt sind wir freunde oder
ja ich war letztens auch zehn tage bei
ihr das war cool
leider hat die eine schöne wohnung
ich frage mich jetzt schon ein komisches
im schnitt sein wird oder schnitt mir
beim essen selber zuzugucken ich werde
wahrscheinlich davor sitzen denken
what the [ __ ] vanessa führst du wirklich
vor der kamera essen ist eine gute idee
was du dich schon mal angeschaut du
siehst nicht gut aus beim essen aber das
essen sind gut aus das sieht super aus
nächste frage papa ich hab mit meinem
speicher gespuckt wie lustig als
fotoapparat auf einer skala von atze
schröder bis bully herbig ich glaube
erst mal so was dazwischen erstmalig
schröder
wer mit seinem berliner dialekt um die
ecke kommt
beate schröder berliner ich weiß jetzt
nicht und manchmal so bully herbig habt
ihr gehört bully herbig es soll neue
buch ist soll ein neuer bully herbig
film rauskommt 2017 und eigentlich
dachte ich also mein erster gedanke war
so ok
das wird scheiße so also bei der humor
wahrheit vor paar jahren lustig und
jetzt halt nicht mehr
aber der trailer ist schon echt cool
also mit diesen ganzen anspielung von
traumschiff surprise und schuh des
manitu und sissi und franz glaube ich
dass ich werde ihn mir angucken
definitiv welchen schulabschluss hast du
mit welchem schnitt und welche weisheit
möchtest du uns mit auf den weg geben
ich habe die fachhochschulreife
das ist nicht das fachabitur und es ist
auch kein abitur ist die
fachhochschulreife
das ist quasi ein bisschen weniger also
ich kann aber damit auf jede fh
gehen aber nicht auf alle universitäten
so manche universitäten nehmen das
trotzdem an aber manche auch nicht und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
super damit zufrieden also ich weiß
nicht ob ich abitur geschafft hätte ich
war doch schon ziemlich faul
und mein schnitt war dafür gut
also ich glaube ich hatte 20 abschnitt
und wenn ich mich damit bewerber dann
kommt es halt ein bisschen besser an als
wenn ich mich durchs abitur quäle und er
am ende irgendwie da so ein 41
durchschnitt ab oder 3,5 oder so was ja
auch okay ist aber es ist halt damit
kommt man schlechter an plätze ran
das ist sowieso wenn ich mich daran
zurückerinnern wie wir was für'n stress
war zum abschluss hin dass man einen
studienplatz ich habe mich an drei
universitäten oder fachhochschulen und
universitäten beworben und ich wurde an
allen drei abgelehnt oder wurde ich an
einer ich glaub ich vor den renn
abgelehnt gut die eine war davon
universität der künste in berlin
da gibt es irgendwie 20 plätze 30 plätze
pro jahr und die bewerber sind ungefähr
bei 1500 da könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen wie schwierig es ist ja
mal meine katzen
ich hab mich dann beim aufgestellt ich
hab auch den universitäten auch keinen
platz bekommen und war dann erst mal so
ein bisschen was mach ich jetzt
und wusste aber dass ich wegen also bei
uns zu hause war alles gut aber ich
musste raus weil es hat nicht mehr
geklappt dass ich zu hause gewohnt hat
ich war 19 und hab da eine ausbildung in
berlin gesucht bei bosna das ist ein
einzelhandel oder großhandel für kunst
waren also das was alles künstler
brauchen pinsel leinwände aber auch halt
so speziellere sachen wie speckstein und
also alles was ein künstler braucht habe
ich da verkauft und das habe ich drei
monate gemacht bis ich gemerkt habe dass
ich mag zwar kunst und das war cool dass
künstler eingekauft haben und dass man
so viel mit denen so geredet hat aber
einzelhandels einzelhandel und das hat
mich überhaupt nicht erfüllt und die
entscheidung war noch mal richtig hart
zu sagen dass ich diese ausbildung
abbrechen und in berlin bleibe ohne
irgendwie eine richtige perspektive oder
oder ein ziel oder so aber die
entscheidung habe ich dann gemacht und
habe mir erst mal nebenjob gesucht um
meine miete zahlen zu können
und kurz darauf habe ich deine
ausbildung gefunden die mir so gut
gepasst hat zum gestaltungstechnischen
assistenten eine schulische ausbildung
da habe ich halt gelernt wie man mit
photoshop und was arbeitet und die habe
ich dann auch abgebrochen
nach einem jahr weil dann die sendung
fantastisch kam ja ich glaube es hat
auch noch jemand gefragt was ich vor
fantastisch gemacht habe ich habe eine
ausbildung gemacht
hier habe ich ahne ich hab sie pausiert
ich kann immer wieder zurück zu dieser
ausbildung ich hab das mit dem
schulleiter geklärt er meinte hat mir
aber damals auch geraten dass ich auf
jeden fall diese chance mit der sendung
wahrnehmen soll weil man solche
möglichkeiten gezeigt vor selten und
dass ich dann auch gemacht habe die dann
einfach wahrgenommen hat auch super spaß
ich glaube ich habe ein jahr lang ein
fantastisches gearbeitet
das ist jetzt auch erstmal vorbei falls
die leute sich gefragt haben warum es
nicht mehr läuft
und mein plan für die zukunft ist auf
jeden fall wenn ich mit youtube kein
spaß mehr habe oder es kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ich jemand mit youtube
aufhören würde auch von mir aus wenn es
äußerlich nicht mehr geht wenn ich zum
beispiel fed werde
nein scherz ich meine wenn es welche
äußeren einwirkungen gibt die mich davon
abhalten würde dann kann ich natürlich
nicht sagen dass ich niemals mit youtube
aufhören will
aber ich plane auf jeden fall wenn es
sich so wenn ich zum beispiel weiß wo
jetzt mein weg mich ungefähr hin führt
dann werde ich auf jeden fall nochmal
nach einem studienplatz gucken und mich
für irgendwas spezialisieren oder so
weil youtube läuft dann moment gut und
halt im nächsten moment kannst wieder
nicht gut laufen und das will ich nicht
riskieren dass ich dann nichts mehr hat
da will ich das lieber selber
entscheiden
oh mein gott
die zukunft wollt ihr wissen was ich
esse
das ist eine rolle mit karaoke und
frischkäse und das ist eine rolle mit
ricardo und so und hier habe ich noch
frittiert mit tofu und gucke und so ja
so nächste frage
ja was euch vor youtube gewarnt dass
gemacht wie sieht dein adventskalender
aus falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt
ich habe einen adventskalender video
hochgeladen in dem ich meiner meinung
nach super kreativen adventskalender
gemacht habe ja ein super kreativen
adventskalender und mein adventskalender
ist wie letztes jahr auch ein ikea
adventskalender ungewiss die schokolade
slacker weiß gar nicht mehr was dieses
jahr drin ist auf jeden fall kostet der
13 euro oder so und da sind auf jeden
fall 25 euro gutschein von dirk er drin
das heißt er kostet am ende nur 3 und da
ist sogar ein gewinnspiel mit bei heißt
dass deine karte auch zum beispiel 500
euro sein kann oder 1000 euro
und dann fragst du den kauf kaufen und
muss kein geld dafür ausgeben war ikea
und das ein adventskalender
also es gibt keinen grund buchmacher vor
werbung ja es gibt für mich keinen grund
sich dir nichts macht kann man dummheit
heilen dummheit heilen
ja klar
silvio ja man kann dummheit heilen und
ich sage euch jetzt wie passt gut auf
holt euch ein stift falls ihr euch das
merken wollte dummheit heilt man indem
man sich informiert denn dummheit ist
eigentlich nichts anderes als
unwissenheit wenn sich wenn sich jemand
dumpfer hält dann ist ja eigentlich
unwissend darüber wie man es besser
machen kann oder wie es nicht so dumm
ist zum beispiel wenn in eurer klasse
oder in eurer arbeit jemand etwas dummes
sagt dann sagte ein klima etwas was
falsches
versteht ihr was ich meine welche person
würdest du gerne in diesem moment umarme
euch alle und dann würde ich euch was
mit einem sushi abgeben und dann würde
ich euch wieder nach hause schicken weil
ihr nicht zu meiner wohnung verloren
haben
wie lange sind magst du nicht schon
zusammen und ich froh und ich sind jetzt
drei jahre zusammen 3 und ein bisschen
wow das echt lange drüber nachdenkt nun
ein scheiße fünf sekunden regel nein ist
auch mein urteil gefallen ist ich bin
nicht so eklig wie schwer
ich schwöre ja ja beziehungen max
beziehungen die beziehung zu max ist die
längste die ich bis jetzt hatte ich
hatte in meinem leben außer marvel ich
könnte man auch ein paar mal öfter 10
sophie wir zusammen und wieder
auseinander was
ich hatte in meinem leben also max ist
jetzt die vierte beziehung ich habe
schon drei beziehungen davor also
beziehung die eine gingen sechs monate
die andere ein jahr und die andere
ich glaube drei monate also sind schon
beziehungen sage ich gar nichts also
wenn ihr mit eurem freund drei monats
zusammen seid dann seid ihr definitiv
ein paar nur rückblickend denkt man dann
so wenn man schon länger mit mann
zusammen ist
das andere ist dann halt viele fans
trotzdem können du und dein freund oder
du deine freundin sich sehr lieben wenn
ihr drei monate zusammen seid da ich gar
nicht gegen hast du ein tattoo oder
willst du welche haben ja ich habe vier
tattoos 1 2 3 und 1 auf dem rücken was
man glaube ich noch nie gesehen hat ich
bin mir nicht sicher aber ich glaube das
hat mir noch nie gesehen und ich will
auf jeden fall noch mehr tattoos machen
ach du nimmst du die erste reihe beim
sushi ja das ist gut
ich bin mehr tattoos ich möchte auf
jeden fall noch eine pocahontas hier
oben drauf haben somit dem schilf und
mit den blättern und so ich muss nur
jemanden finden der mir das genau so
sticht wie ich es mir vorstelle
das ist mir ganz wichtig wenn ihr die
katzen
ich muss mal ganz kurz ein ganz
wichtigen tipp habe ich für euch wenn es
um tattoos geht spart euer geld wirklich
sucht euch jemanden aus der es genau so
macht wie ihr es euch vorstellt weil
wenn ihr am anfang darin spart und
irgendwie hier über das wird nur 100
ulrike bei dem mit 250 kostet so sollte
man sich keine tattoos stechen lassen
cook immer danach was ihr gefällt und
nicht wie viel es kostet und wenn es zu
viel kostet dann spaß wenn du es
wirklich haben willst dann wirst du auch
so lange warten können
diese katzen immer wenn ich immer wenn
ich auf dem sofa chile denn schlafen sie
und jedes mal wenn ich was tun muss und
es gerne hätte dass sie schlafen kanton
tier um ne aber man liebt sie
wie bin ich auf die idee gekommen
youtube videos zu drehen
also ich habe gehört dass man vor einer
kamera essen kann und dann haben wir
vorher kamera essen das klingt ja leicht
weimar dass er hier ist das nicht so
leicht vor der kamera zu essen kostet
sehr viel überwindung und man kann nicht
schneiden
also das klassische marketing ist ist
immer ein bisschen längeren schneidet
nicht
und das habe ich noch nie glaube ich
gemacht ein um geschnittenes video von
mir jetzt seht ihr auch mal wie ich
wirklich bin
diskus 1
jetzt abonnieren mich alle leute weil
sie wissen wer ich wirklich bin
nur am scheiße bauen den ganzen tag vor
allem habe ich ja den perfekten job ich
bin die ganze zeit zu hause das heißt
ich bin den ganzen tag mit den ganzen
zusammen max freut sich immer weil er ja
immer für neue skript und so und doppel
freude im büro dreht bei denen er kommt
aus und denkt sich eure schönen die
katzen und ich krieg das schon so einen
hals weiß nicht ob ich sie jeden tag
sehe 24 stunden
außerdem bin ich mal aus dem haus gehen
dann nehme ich sie mit einer leine
ich liebe meine katzen jetzt werde aber
langsam voll und ganz viel übrig also
wie bin ich dazu gekommen youtube videos
zu machen oder was hat mich dazu bewegt
erfahrt ihr jetzt
ich nehme nur ganz kurz zuschlug ich
habe schon damals zu außenseiter zeiten
also vor sieben acht jahren sechs jahren
habe ich schon angeschaut und fand es
halt immer super geil
es gab ja damals so haben quasi so die
nerds geschaut die coolen leute haben
sich überhaupt nicht dafür interessiert
also so mehr tanz und après gab es jetzt
für videos machen jeder soll machen was
er will
das war einfach nichts für coole
menschen das wahrheit für diese
außenseiter hat für diese nötigen
irgendwie haben sie komische hobbys und
schon leute beim essen zu leute nicht
ganz
und dann hab ich videos geschaut und
dann habe ich irgendwann immer gedacht
so auch maniche wird auch kenne ich habe
so viele ideen und das könnte ich ja
drehen und ich würde dann immer so
machen und so was würde ich könnte ich
denn machen
ich hab mich nie getraut weiß auch es
gibt also ich verstehe den punkt wenn
man zum beispiel zu hause wohnt und mit
videos machen würde
und am nächsten tag in die schule müsste
das wäre ganz schön scheiße also weil
ich habe ja in berlin gewohnt als ich
angefangen habe ich mal ein bisschen
mehr als drei jahren in berlin
und dann habe ich jetzt angefangen und
wenn ich dann zum beispiel zur arbeit
gegangen bin hat es halt keiner gewusst
weil die kannten mich halt nicht aber
wenn man halt zur schule geht die tekken
natürlich sofort wenn also du musst ja
auch irgendwie posten und so teilen
damit die leute sich das angucken und ja
das wäre kacke alkan viele verstehen die
sich einfach nicht trauen weil sie angst
haben in der schule deswegen gemobbt zu
werden oder so weil es gibt ohne scheiß
es gibt nirgends so viele menschen wie
in der schule
das ist mir nach paar jahren auch
irgendwann so ganz klar geworden dass
also in der erwachsenenwelt sag ich mal
witze auch gemobbt und so dass kippst
alles bei der arbeit und so und es gibt
immer noch viele menschen aber die
schulzeit alter was man sich dafür
gedanken machen muss wie krank das ist
das also ich weiß noch wie verzweifelt
ich manchmal morgens in meinem
kleiderschrank stand kleiderschrank
stand und ich war völlig fertig weil ich
nicht ein outfit gefunden habe was was
was mir gerade gefällt wir hatten auch
niemals so viel geld also ich hab immer
klamotten von meiner schwester gehabt
oder halt mal was bekommen aber das ist
dann halt auch mal nicht so cool gewesen
wie diese ganzen hollister polizei eine
zeit lang in diese ganzen skater
klamotten
daran erinnere ich mich noch nicht
erkannten nicht mehr alle nicht leisten
konnte und deshalb stand ich halt immer
war ein kleiderschrank obama völlig
verzweifelt weil ich nichts gefunden
habe was schönes oder was cool ist
und heutzutage ist das so ich zähl t
shirt mit bakula links unten burger
drauf und fühle mich cool und mirjam ein
ja auch nicht gedanken darüber was meine
ich kann mir heute auch coole sachen
leisten als ich damals getragen habe
aber nee ich will damit sagen jeder der
schulzeit hast allein aus dem grund
nicht wegen lernstoff und so aber allein
aus dem grund weil er nicht so ganz mit
dieser fiesen welt klarkommt kann ich
absolut verstehen was da womit man damit
konfrontiert wird also das will ich
nicht noch mal haben irgendwelche mädels
klicken über dich lästern und dann bis
plötzlich das opfer des klasse und jeder
lacht wenn nun raum kommst einer freut
euch darauf für die die eine schöne
schulzeit haben ich hatte auch eine zeit
eine schöne schulzeit
also ich hatte ich hatte eine gute
schulzeit ich hatte leute die mich
geglaubt haben oder so aber ich habe
manchmal infekt darauf geben können
manchmal nicht aber manchmal schon
und ich habe meine freunde also ein paar
und das hat mir gereicht
meine schulnoten dem ok so und aber
jetzt wenn ich so zurückdenke
ich würde nicht noch mal gerne in die
schule gehen auch wenn das manche
erwachsene sagen mit 30 so ja und später
musste dann arbeiten und basis viel
anstrengender weil ja also schule ist
die beste zeit denken wir mal so nein
bei wenn du arbeitest dann arbeitest du
kriegst sein geld kommt zu hause kann
sich spannend schüler haben wohl das
schwierigste leben überhaupt die müssen
die ganz neue sachen lernen dass zum 1
bei der arbeit wenn ich neue sachen da
machst du deine arbeit so eine schule
lernst du die ganze zeit neue sachen
muss sie alle behalten muss musstest
schreiben und manchmal hat man ja sogar
in einer woche weiß ich noch so viel
test wo dann darüber diskutiert wurde ob
das überhaupt noch rechtens ist und ich
glaube wenn du in der schule darüber
diskutieren muss ob es rechtens ist wie
viele tests kommen
dann kann es auch schon nicht rechtens
seien vier testern ein blick dann hast
du die ganze zeit damit verbracht hat zu
lernen und für die schule was zu tun
dann kommst du aus dem dann kommst aus
den acht stunden tag nach hause und
macht erstmal hausaufgaben drei stunden
und im sommer führen test lernen also
keiner kann mir erzählen dass die arbeit
anstrengender ist keine und bei der uni
ist glaube ich genauso also dass auch
vollen arsch voll arbeit ich muss gucken
was die katze macht möchte noch jemand
was ich habe genau was übrig ich hoffe
ich konnte euch damit ein bisschen
entertainer vielleicht habt ihr auch was
gegessen
also das wäre schön dass ich nicht
alleine essen wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten video wieder und fahrzeug das
gefallen hat lasse ich mich auf jeden
fall wissen falls euch nicht gefallen
hat könnt ihr es auch sagen aber sag mir
bitte nicht was ihr ist nicht leiden
können wenn leute essen weil ich habe
euch am anfang gewarnt und ich hab
gegessen und also wieder konstruktive
kritik vielleicht wollte ich alles kann
das kann ich noch annehmen oder so na
gut wir sehen uns dann das nächste mal
bis dann